let's give it to Liz how you doing Liz
hi good night thank you thank you
well I am a single mom and a few weeks I
saw that you
um make a question or well not a
question but you make um kind of a
comment that says that um single moms
met make better men's uh
so I wanted to ask what things do I have
to do to make my son an alpha and how do
how can I um
yes how what things do I have to make so
he can be a better man
okay so just so I understand your
questions so you're a single mom you've
got a son how old is he how old is he
he is he's five years old
and his father where's his father
um his father is in another state and
they don't have any emulation she
okay don't talk to each other
no uh not because of me is his decision
okay I see
um so do you have a strong virtuous
father that's nearby or a brother that
can you know play the role of a stand-in
uh dad you know like an uncle for him
um yes I have uh my father he is uh he's
a good um
a good uh I I think he's a good man and
that he's strong and he can teach a lot
of things
yeah so he needs to be taught how to
become a man by being around men right
like kids kids watch what uh adults do
and they listen to very little of what
they say especially when they come to
teenagers like if you want to see how
little a kid listens to you as a parent
wait till they turn into a teenager like
wait till they hit puberty right so
allow him opportunities to spend time
with your dad if do you have any
brothers that are close by
uh I have a brother but he lives in
another
state so he really doesn't see him a lot
but when they talk to each other on I
don't know
um like a phone call or something they
play like they talk about dinosaurs or
space or cars and I think that um is
something that I tried to tell and talk
to him about but I think it's better
when it comes from a man
got it um why doesn't the father want
anything to do with your son
um he has a perception that um
he doesn't want to be a bother so he
just disappeared from our lives like um
a lot of time ago I don't know maybe
four or five years ago four years ago he
disappeared okay but yes you guys were
together for the first year ago
sorry um no we were
sorry sorry he wanted to make his what
um no we we were like we were together
like um I was his girlfriend and he was
my boyfriend but we were not together
like living together or something we
um we meet but we always live in
different states
okay so it was like more of a hookup
then
um yeah I mean we were on our
relationship when I got pregnant but um
then after we he we we never like uh
were living together or something yes
yes okay so so it ended up you just
picking the wrong guy so my
recommendation for a kid that's five is
there's probably an opera I mean there's
probably an opportunity for him to get
some exposure to men and other boys in
something like Boy Scouts
um I would I would probably put them in
that
um and then when he gets a little bit
older maybe about six or seven I mean
you could even start them now at five
like I see small children at the dojos
too Brigham bring him to some Karate
Dojo and let him learn how to fight let
him you know get into combat with other
kids let him learn how to defend himself
it's an incredibly useful tool and it's
probably one of the most masculine
Pursuits that boys without fathers can
get into that's those would be my two
main recommendations grandfather and get
him into Boy Scouts and probably uh some
kind of Dojo some sort of Combat Sports
okay actually he really likes box so and
he won't put him in the Box glasses so I
will do it
I'm good thank you so much for your
advice
take care I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out